eine rote zipfelmütze festes schuhwerk
ein weißer bart und die laterne
denn er schuftet im bergbau das ist der
der originaltext seine wiege in
gräfenroda in thüringen die gartenzwerg
manufaktur philipp griebel ist eine der
letzten in deutschland herrscher in
diesen zwergenland ist reinhard griebel
und zwar schon in vierter generation
sein urgroßvater philipp griebel
gründete das unternehmen 1874 von seiner
werkstatt ausbrach der zwerg zu seinem
globalen siegeszug auf er stammt aus dem
bergbau als nachbildung der bergmänner
als symbol des fleißes und im bergbau
hatte man eine zipfelmütze auf und diese
gingen natürlich etwas über diesen
schulterbereich damit kein gestein
reingefallen ist der kopf ist normal
groß der körper ist etwas getrunken es
in kleinere menschen und die bergwerk
brachte man die kleinen menschen und
deswegen auch diese zwerge als solches
zunächst wurden modelle für verschiedene
berufsgruppen produziert zum beispiel
für die metzger als
schaufensterdekoration mit schaufel und
schürze tauchten sie erst mitte des
vergangenen jahrhunderts sind in
privatgärten auf zuerst in den deutschen
und später weltweit immer als symbol für
fließen obwohl sie doch nie wirklich war
der arbeit helfen konnten
[Musik]
die produktion der gartenzwerge in
gräfenroda hat sich in den vergangenen
100 jahren kaum verändert die figuren
aus flüssigem ton müssen einige stunden
trocknen bevor die nähte mit einem
schwamm verputzt werden
[Musik]
anschließend werden sie bei mehr als
1000 grad celsius gebrannt
erst danach werden sie von hand und mit
viel geduld und liebe freiheit und das
könnte die zukunft der zwerge seien eine
geburt in 3d drucker den plan dafür gibt
es einfach im internet zum herunterladen
zb für karl aktuell das maskottchen der
bundesgartenschau in heilbronn
dort steht er quasi als der gartenzwerg
der zukunft
er verbindet tradition mit moderner
technik
die digitalisierung wird unsere städte
verändern wird unser leben verändern und
deshalb passt unser digitaler karl
glaube ich ganz gut in diese
gesellschaftliche veränderung die im
moment vor uns liegt der frische wind
kommt vielleicht gerade recht denn viele
deutsche wollen gar keinen gartenzwerg
mehr im eigenen garten er gilt ihnen als
inbegriff von spießigkeit und kitsch bei
gartentage echten schlechteste mit haben
und ich wahrscheinlich da ist mir
peinlich
mir hat sich also der sinn eines
gartenzwergs bisher noch nicht
erschlossen ich habe allerdings auch
noch nicht viel zeit dafür verwendet ich
hab noch war erbstücke dies setzt sich
handelt in die ecke aber ich würde mir
jetzt keiner mehr kaufen
dabei ist er einfach typisch deutsch
noch immer tummeln sich millionen zwerge
im land zurück nach gräfenroda veronika
jäger bemalt die zwerge hier schon seit
mehr als 30 jahren
sie liebt sie auch im eigenen garten nur
nicht zu viele wenige auserwählte dürfen
sich dort verstecken oder bei ihr
faulenzen
der liebling ist mein felix der liegende
weil mein vater so hieß und der wurde so
genannt ausgerechnet weil ein besonders
schön auf mit einem sehr sehr schönen
gesicht und dadurch ist das mein
liebling geworden
aufträge hat reinhard griebel übrigens
immer noch viele bis nach frankreich und
schweden schickte er seine zwerge
trotzdem könnte hier bald schluss sein
der ruhestand heißt das dass der
original gartenzwerg jetzt vom
aussterben bedroht ist
ich gebe mir große mühe dass es
weitergeht mit den kleinen nichten mit
roten zipfelmützen
denn wenn man den burschen doch in die
augen schaut nach warum sollten die
aussterben es war wirklich war darum für
die manufaktur sucht er deshalb einen
nachfolger jemanden der sich auch in
zukunft um die kleinen zwerge kümmert
[Musik]